Okay. So we are back to the code and all
I have done is added the translate function to our program.
So what this code is doing now, is saying, for
each file or for each photo, inside our folder, rename it.
Here is the old file name and here is the
new file name devoid of any numbers. Now my hypothesis is
that if I save and run this program, all of the
photo files will be renamed and we'll see the secret message.
So let me go ahead and save it and run the program.
Oh wow. That clearly did not work. Would you
mind reading through this editor and telling us what
you think is the problem? Once you have a
hypothesis, feel free to enter it into the box provided.